so right now I'm not the strongest I've
been and I'm not the biggest I've been
I'm training for a kind of all-round
performance training for flexibility
mobility strength speed endurance all
those things all at once
however there was a time when I was more
interested in just building sighs I
don't know that quite a few of you guys
watching this I probably also interested
in building size especially those hard
gainers and people who just want to bulk
up and fill out their clothes so I
thought in this video I talked about how
to train for size in particular and some
of the mistakes that people make when
they're trying to pack on muscle so a
lot of the advice when it comes to
bulking is to use the compound lift so
that means your squats that means your
deadlifts and it means your benchpress
and the theory goes the training with
these exercises uses more muscles all at
once builds more strength and as such
triggers a greater cascade of
testosterone growth hormone and other
metabolites and hormones that lead to
anabolism growth it's like taking
steroids without having to take steroids
however this information although it's
not incorrect isn't actually
particularly good advice when it comes
to building muscle and the reason for
this is that whilst doing deadlifts and
benchpress etc will trigger a massive
spike in growth hormone and testosterone
it's very short-lived it's not going to
stick around in your blood for a long
period of time in order to encourage
more anabolism it's actually just going
to disappear very shortly after and not
impact on your muscle building
subsequently having sex watching action
films being competitive these things
also spike testosterone but you're not
going to notice that you become bulkier
just by doing them it's the same thing
with compound lifts I'm not saying that
compound lifts aren't useful but if
you're doing them for a hormone spike
because you think it's gonna boost your
muscle building that's actually been
shown to be incorrect and anyways if
it's just about using more muscles then
surely you don't need to do compound
lifts in particular surely it'd be just
as effective to do a full body routine I
would say you should keep your compound
lifts as a big part of your training
because they do force it to use a lot of
strength and building strength will
build a muscle when you build strength
you cause micro tears that they come
back thicker and that's
this makes the muscles harder and fuller
so lifting heavy weights is advisable at
the same time building big strong legs
and building that yoke these are things
that gonna make you look overall bigger
however don't rely on them and don't
assume that compound lifts are far more
effective than higher rep ranges
isolation movements because actually if
you look at any bodybuilder and these
are the people who are really big aren't
they if you look at any bodybuilder they
use a lot of isolation exercises they
use high rep ranges they build up the
metabolic stress in the muscles and
that's what leads to subsequent growth
so a lot of people will say we can't
train like a bodybuilder they all take
steroids and that's why they get their
results and yes taking steroids of
course causes them to get greater
results from the same training however
you can still benefit from the same
training methods it's just that you
won't get quite the same extreme results
this is still the optimum method for
packing on size and muscle otherwise
they wouldn't do it and that's why I do
recommend a kind of power building
regime if you're looking to bulk and if
you're looking to pack on muscle start
with the big heavy compound lifts and
then move on to the isolation work and
do focus on those higher rep ranges 20
30 etc to really pump the muscles you
want to fill the pump basically by
combining heavy compound moves and
higher reps on the isolation moves
ideally with some slow eccentrics we can
maximize the three main stimuli for
hypertrophy muscle damage metabolic
stress and mechanical tension and don't
forget to do some spot work on those
in-between muscles too taking the time
to do some shrugs or focusing more on
your triceps to counterbalance your
biceps will go a long way to making you
look much more massive in terms of the
structure and ordering of your exercises
you should of course but the compound
moves at the start and then the
isolation movements at the end reason
being a because of course you need more
strength through the compound movements
you can't do them fatigued that will
increase the risk of injury but be
because whilst I'm saying you won't get
a huge spike in growth hormone etc there
is some evidence to suggest that spiking
your great forming and your testosterone
with a compound movement and then
immediately
to doing an isolation movement might
mean that you get better benefits from
that isolation movement because of your
elevated hormone levels the study i
looked at i'm not hundred percent
convinced by there were messed illogical
problems however it certainly can't hurt
to give it a go there volume and
frequency are also really important and
there are plenty of studies now that
demonstrate that training each body part
more than once a week is going to be
really good for building size and
strength so if you can and something
like a ppl ppl routine would be really
good that means push-pull legs push-pull
legs alternatively you could be
principal legs and then a whole body day
in other words you're just trying to
make sure you hit those muscles twice
and doing lots of exercises for each one
during your training essentially the
more you can curl and more you compress
and the more you can squat without
burning out the more growth you're gonna
see and this is something else that's
really important burning out because a
lot of people who want to add massive
size they will try and exercise as much
as possible they always wanted this
they're desperate to see results quickly
they want to put in a hundreds an effort
instead of go to the gym every single
day and they're there for hours this is
actually a mistake because if you want
to build muscle and build size you need
to spend more time being anabolic and
less time being catabolic so your body
has to space anabolism and catabolism
which essentially equates to your
sympathetic nervous system and your
parasympathetic nervous system or fight
and flight and rest and digest
you're either amped up focused working
hard and that's when you're burning fat
for energy or you're relaxed you're calm
you're recuperating and this is when
you're building muscle and restoring
tissue and healing wounds we need to
spend as much time as possible in that
anabolic state the thing to recognize is
that your body doesn't register a
difference between physiological and
psychological stress anabolism and
catabolism are simply different terms
for rest and digest and fight-or-flight
so if you're constantly stressed with
work if you're not getting enough sleep
if you're constantly spiking your blood
sugar or if you're generally in an
anxious person you'll be increasing your
heart rate producing cortisol and
adrenaline and burning fat rather than
building muscle the reason we get
butterflies when we're stressed is that
either digestive system has been
suppressed the reason we get ill is
because chronic stress suppresses our
immune system as well
training itself is a big physiological
stressor so if you want to grow instead
of just constantly breaking yourself
down you need to pay that debt with rest
and recuperation work hard rest hard
don't underestimate the role of
psychology in bulking and consider
altering your lifestyle in order to
facilitate the kind of gains you're
interested in have the very least
consider finding ways to better manage
stress like meditation and CBT you might
also notice that a lot of the things
that are great for energy and burning
fat are therefore not so useful for
bulking so you want to focus on being as
relaxed as possible if you want to get
as big as possible and this is what I
mean by living like a lion and when you
eat need to eat big as well countless
studies show that one gram of protein
for every pound of body weight is
roughly the target you should be aiming
for with your protein but to be honest
in my experience you can't have too much
so add to protein shakes into your
current routine not help you to build
more strength taking caffeine protein
before you go to sleep is another good
way to prevent your blood sugar from
dropping putting you into a catabolic
state because it releases the protein
more slowly into your body therefore
making sure you have a constant supply
of amino acids to keep on building
muscle when you've got that nice spike
in testosterone and growth hormone you
also want to eat lots of carbs though
once I've talked on this channel about
the benefits of going lower carb or
using intermittent fasting when it comes
to just bulking a building size you want
to keep those carbs coming in reason
being first of all low carbs means a low
testosterone there's many studies to
show that if you go to low carb at the
same time you want to keep your energy
levels high because low energy levels is
once again a stressor your body reacts
to that by increasing cortisol and
myostatin which breaks down muscle
tissue you want to maintain as much as
possible in a calorie surplus being in a
calorie and nutrient surplus activates a
protein called mTOR mammalian target of
rapamycin this in turn is what triggers
protein synthesis increasing the
production of igf-1 and other chemical
signals BCAAs whether natural or
supplemented even tiny amounts of
leucine can be enough to trigger mTOR to
keep snacks and supplements to hand of
course saturated fats are also really
important for building muscle and
bulking up saturated fats contain
cholesterol cholesterol is what your
body makes your sex hormones from yes
drone is a sex hormone so we think more
saturated fats can raise the
testosterone levels and thus help you to
build more muscle milk is a particularly
great source full fat milk in particular
in fact some people use the go mad diet
a gallon of milk a day and they say that
drinking that much milk can cause a
sudden huge surge in muscle building and
testosterone I don't recommend that one
because it's a bit too much fat you can
have too much of a good thing it's not
overall very healthy something else that
you can try taking in terms of
supplements is creatine creatine
increases your energy levels by helping
a bunch of recycle and reuse ATP
adenosine triphosphate what creatine
also does is it encourages intracellular
retention of water so your muscles will
hold on to more water and that will make
them look slightly swollen and you could
expect to see up to an inch of growth in
your biceps there are such things as
creatine non-responders so you might not
see this and you're the extent to which
you see growth might vary and of course
that water attention isn't gonna make
you any stronger however this just size
you want then trying to take creatine as
well certainly can't hurt it might be an
easy way to gain some size overnight
almost and whilst you're trying to get
lots of protein and whilst trying to get
lots of carbs I also recommend that you
eat any Tricia's diet because there's
all sorts of nutrients in our diets help
us to build bigger muscle things like
vitamin C prevent the breakdown of
muscle tissue things like calcium will
make your tendons stronger making you
stronger in the gym meaning you can lift
more money that you grow more don't make
the mistake of following me if why I am
diet if it fits in your macros yeah I
completely did that acting them wrong
don't make that mistake of just eating
any kind of junk because you're getting
enough calories because yeah you will
but you also you'll be weaker and it's
not good for you in the long term and in
the short term eating a nutritious diet
getting all of those carbs and all of
the protein from a nutritious diet
that's much better for you do you think
of lions as being ferocious predators
and running after their prey tracking
them down always being on the go being
kings of the jungle but in reality Lions
actually spend a lot of their time just
lounging around and particularly the
male lions there's a good reason for
this because they're conserving energy
it doesn't actually make any sense for
life
be on the go if they lounge around they
can survive longer on less food and it
means they build more fast-twitch muscle
fibers so that when they do see an
antelope sprint across the savanna they
can give chase much more effectively
they know when to strike they go either
all out or they're resting and if you
want to bulk and gain size that's how
you need to be you need to be either all
out or not moving at all waiting eating
and sleeping take fans of useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please jet around comment
down below and let me know if you have
any tips for gaining size and mass I've
got lots more like this on the way as
always we're going to be looking at how
to train your abs to become visible even
at ten percent plus body fat going to be
looking at single leg training jump
height training night wing training body
weight training that all sounds cool
then stick around subscribe and I'll see
you next time
bye for now